انضموا الينا من عمان لواء فايزه دويريع
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لودوير اهلا
بك ما دلالات استهداف كياف بهذه الوتيره
المكثفه والمتسارعه
يعني هو نوع من التشعيد منذ اسابيع تشهد
الساحه ساحه المعارف تصعيد متبادل من كلا
الجانبين الجانب وكل جانب بانطلاقا من
القدرات الكامله لديه القوات الروسيه
تساعد في بعدي الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ خاصه الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه في
المرات في المرات السابقه بالاضافه الى
محاوله اكمال الدوره العمليه في مدينه
باقمه والسيطره على الجيب المتبقي في
الجنوب الغربي منها في المقابل نجد ان
اوكرانيا كذلك بدات بالتصعيد وتصعدها تركز
كذلك في بعدين استخدام الطائرات المسيره
تحديدا في منطقه شبه جزيره القرن ثم تطور
الى استخدام عمليات اطلق عليها من الجانب
الروسي لعمليات التقريبيه في تقريب سكه
الحديد وخروج احد القطارات عن مسارهم ثم
بدا استخدام صواريخ ظل العاصفه وهي مداها
ثلاث مئه كيلو متر كما انها قامت بالتصعيد
في ارض المعركه من قبل القوات الارضيه حيث
استعادت بناء على التصريحات الاوكرانيه
على عشرين كيلو متر مربع في اكتاف المنطقه
الدفاعيه المحيطه وفي مسائل وفي الليله
الماضيه حاولت ان تنفذ عمليات قد اسميها
الاستطلاع بالقوه باتجاه
لو بقينا في كييف فايز
وما رايك فيما تفيده
الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن اسقاط جميع
الطائرات المسيره ويحدد انها من نوع شاهد
وهذه الطائرات هي متفجره بالاساس هل معنى
ذلك انها لم تصب ايا من الاهداف
الاوكرانيه التي اطلقت من اجلها
يعني اذا اخذنا بالتصريح بان جميع
الطائرات تم اسقاطها واسقاط الطائرات
المسير طائرات شاهد 129 او 136 يعتبر امرا
سهلا قياسا مع التعامل مع الصواريخ ولكن
السؤال الاكبر لماذا بدات التركيز على
ارسال اعداد كبيره من الطائرات المسيره
قبل اطلاق الصواريخ هنا تكون هي اشاره ان
هذه الطائرات اولا الطائرات بطيئه تحتاج
الى وقت كبير حتى تصل الى
قياسا كما يقال المسافه والوقت ولكنها يتم
برمجتها على ان تصل قبل موجات اطلاق
الصواريخ لماذا لانه مجرد ان تقوم شبكات
الرادار بكشف اهداف جويه قائمه لابد من
تفعيل شبكات الرادار وهنا تبدا ارسال
الموجات النبض الراداري وتتمكن القوات
الروسيه من جديده اماكن هذه المنظومات
الراداريه
وكذلك منظومات الصواريخ فيكون التعامل
معها من خلال استخدام الصواريخ اي كان
استخدام الطائرات المسيره هو الخطوه
التمهيديه لانجاح الضربات الصاروخيه
وبالتالي لا يشير ايضا الى تطور في الاداء
الاوكراني في التصدي لهذه المسيرات بالنظر
الى عدد الطائرات المسيره التي تم تدميرها
قبل الهجوم على ثياب امام هذه القدرات
وامام الوعود الغربيه بتقديم المزيد من
الدعم في هذا المجال
لاوكرانيا كيف ستتطور في المقابل
استراتيجيه الروس في التعامل مع هذه
المعطيات
يعني اولا عمليه نسبه النجاح دعيني اقول
تختلف من يوم الى اخر بالامس كانت النسبه
تقريبا 66% اليوم استنادا الى التصريحات
الاوكرانيه تقريبا 100% قبلها كانت تصل
الى 90% اذا هناك نجاحات ونجاح واخفاق في
التصدي لهذه الطائرات وهذا له العديد من
الاسباب والمسببات لماذا الان اعداد
الطائرات خط الطيران او ارتفاع او المحركه
السمتي لهذه الطائرات زوايا الاقتراب
التوقيت الذي تبدا به عمليات التشويش اذا
هناك العديد من النقاط التي تجهز استخدام
الاسلحه المضاده ووصولها الى النسبه
المطلقه او ان تكون دون ذلك ولكن ماذا هذا
يعني بالنسبه لروسيا روسيا اعتقد انها
ترقد بعدا اخر قد يكون مختلفا كليا بالامس
كان الحديث عن طائر تجويد من الطائرات
الجيل الرابع الاف 16 وهي طائره ميزاتها
صغيره الحجم تقليديه التكاليف اذا قارنا
بين الطائره 16 والاف 15
ثمنها في الحد الاقصى 26 مليون دولار
بينما الطيارات الاخرى تتجاوز في بعض
الحالات الثمرين مليون دولار مضاف الى ذلك
انها طائره متعدده المهام وطائره التفوق
جوي وبالتالي اعتقد ان الجانب الروسي يقرا
المشهد كامل ماذا عن هجوم الربيع هل سيكون
هجوما بريا هل سيكون هجوما جه بريا مدعوما
بقوات جويه ام سيكون ثلاثي الابعاد اشكرك
لواء فايزه دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه من عمان